wow but this is where not making threes  consistently  makes it a little more difficult for you  here with under two minutes to go  they've shot it well but they've cooled  off since the first half tonsich knocks  down the three as he's heating up  at just the right time that might be a  little bit too much though  [Applause]  putting dallas up by 11 was the luca  donchette step back  he's just a different player later in  the game he has  so much confidence as a player  regardless to where his game is  where his shot making is nice little  stop  has some of the best breaks in the game  and uh  big time three for doncic  hopefully there's a long warranty on  those brake pads  you gotta have brakes you have to have  [Music]  22 points 12 wards 12